pauleta monsieur gérard manuel merci
monsieur le président le cher collègue
monsieur le premier ministre je reviens
pas que instant sur le taffetas et ces
négociations transatlantiques
ces dernières se font sous le sceau du
secret et les seuls bribes d'éléments
nous parviennent des usa et elles sont
pour le moins inquiétante tant sur le
fond que sur le calendrier sur le
calendrier du d'abord les usa voudrais
conclure au pas de charge avant la fin
du mandat du président obama en est il
et quant au fond
l'élimination annoncé des droits de
douane sur 97% des produits échangés est
très préoccupante
en effet dans le secteur agroalimentaire
l'union européenne a mise en place des
normes sanitaires environnementales au
bénéfice des consommateurs européens que
nos agriculteurs doivent suivre il en va
de même de la traçabilité d'alimentation
dont enfin objectif d'exigence
nécessaire et qui seraient mises à mal
par ces négociations qu'en sera-t-il
demain de nos produits d'excellence
comme par exemple l'ensemble des aoc
qu'en serait-il aussi de l'ensemble des
productions produit un coût supérieur
notamment sans ogm et dans des
conditions respectueuses de
l'environnement
pour leur part les agriculteurs
américains ne sont pas soumis à toutes
ces règles
ce qui fait craindre une distorsion
forte de concurrence
monsieur le premier ministre la france a
une responsabilité forte concernant ces
négociations le monde a donné la
commission européenne ne doit pas être
un blanc seing monsieur le premier
ministre je vous demande d'informer la
représentation nationale sur l'état
actuel de ces discussions sur les
éléments qui ferait ou nos processus et
sur les moyens de protéger l'excellence
de notre filière agricole et
agroalimentaire monsieur le premier
ministre est de votre responsabilité de
faire un point précis sur la situation
dans faire corriger les défauts et même
de mettre fin si le fallait à cette
négociation
merci monsieur manuel la parlait qu'à
monsieur jean marc ayrault ministre des
affaires étrangères et du développement
international sur le président remercie
monsieur le député girard manuelles jeux
vient donc compléter la réponse que je
viens de faire à thierry benoit il ya
quelques instants sur le traité
transatlantique de commerce
c'est vrai que
il faut suivre avec une très grande
vigilance est négociations après la
session de février il y aura la cession
à la fin du mois à bruxelles et d'autres
qui se poursuivront d'ici l'été
matthias fekl secrétaires d'état
aujourd'hui à jakarta a eu l'occasion de
le dire ici devant la représentation
nationale
le contenu de l'accord doit primer sur
calendrier et je le dis clairement nous
ne soutiendrons pas un accord qui serait
déséquilibré et se ferait au détriment
de notre économie mais aussi de nos
valeurs dans le cadre des négociations
en cours
les propositions américaines reste à ce
stade en deçà de nos attentes
vous connaissez les points de vigilance
la france considère comme non négociable
notamment le respect des choix
démocratiques en matière de régulation
je pense à la défense des préférences
alimentaires
vous avez évoqué plusieurs sujets
concernant l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire que j'ai déjà
développé tout à l'heure je suis en
accord avec ce que vous avez dit il
c'est aussi l'exclusion de certains
secteurs notamment je pense à
l'audiovisuel aux produits culturels la
protection des données personnelles
la défense des services publics et des
modalités de règlement des litiges entre
l'état et les entreprises et donc sur la
transparence
vous avez totalement raison la france
s'est battue au niveau de l'union
européenne pour que les documents soient
totalement accessible la présidence de
la commission des affaires européennes
rang se rendra d'ailleurs là où sont mis
les documents à disposition des
parlementaires
et en ce qui concerne les propositions
américaines je dois le dire elles sont
insuffisantes à ce stade c'est clair
nous n'accepterons pas je les dis
d'ailleurs à mon homologue john kerry un
traité a minima c'est un choix
particulièrement exigeants et vigilants
merci la parole et